die samsung auf inspektion voller sorge
der reis den er auf seinen feldern im
osten clemens angepflanzt hat ist kaum
mehr zu retten gelbe spitzen die blätter
zusammengerollt der landwirt hat viel
investiert und keine hoffnung dass das
noch was wird
hier sehen wir einen teil des feldes
decke
und hier sehen wir wie es vertrocknet
das blatt hat sich bereits geschlossen
damit sie nicht zu viel sonne abbekommt
und so schützt sie sich dieser steht
wirklich unter stress die wurzeln
müssten mehr entwickelt sein die sind
sehr oberflächlich und haben keine
chance irgendwo feuchtigkeit zu forden
dieser pflanze wird nichts produzieren
zwischen turin und mailand hat es seit
januar keinen richtigen regen gegeben
auf seinen 100 hektar land wird dieser
wohl 70 prozent der geplanten ahnte
verlieren und das in der reiskammer
italiens die sonst mehr als die hälfte
der europäischen reisernte produziert
in dieser zeit hätte das alles voll mit
wasser sein sollen aber ich habe mich
schweren herzens entschieden dieses
reisfeld nicht mehr zu bewässern ich
will nicht sagen dass ich es auf gebe
weil das etwas wirklich schreckliches
wir können uns nicht daran erinnern
verluste diesen ausmaßes oder auch
kleinere gehabt sollen keine erinnerung
auf seinem hof ist es jetzt sehr still
sein angestellter ist nicht da und die
seb hat viel zeit die maschinen und
traktoren stehen still
es sind zehn aber zurzeit arbeiten zu
das ist schade
[Musik]
das dürre desaster trifft das piemont
und lombardei sie sind abhängig vom co
doch der ist zu einem rinnsal verkümmert
kann italiens korn und reiskammer nicht
mehr versorgen auch mais oder gemüse
verdorren kein wirklicher regen dazu
eine immense hitzewelle experten
sprechen von folgen des klimawandels
am gardasee ist von dem wassermangel
oberflächlich noch wenig zu spüren
touristen genießen den urlaub das wasser
doch der kampf darum hat längst begonnen
denn das größte wasserreservoir
oberitalien versorgte mit den fluss
münchen auf den fluss po mit wasser
jetzt soll die abflussmenge erhöht
werden die schleusen viel mehr
durchlassen
dabei sinkt der pegel auch am gardasee
gefährlich schnell beobachtet petrowa 10
der seit 30 jahren boote an touristen
vermietet und den see in und auswendig
kennt
eine dürre wie diese mit einem so
niedrigen level im juni ehrlich gesagt
daran kann ich mich nicht erinnern es
gab jahre da hatten wir das aber im
spätsommer also ende august
wenn der wasserpegel feld hätte das
auswirkungen auf die schifffahrt und auf
die hydro stromgewinnung und schließlich
braucht noch touristen wasser trotzdem
man bis jetzt in der not helfen
es ist wichtig jetzt mehr wasser für den
landwirtschaftlichen anbau abzugeben
aber in einigen fällen könnte das
bewässerungssystem viel sparsamer sein
ich sehe bilder wo wir immer noch per
überschwemmung bewässern vielleicht
würde in diesen fällen die tropfen
bewässerung ausreichen
auch aus den südlichen alpen floss stets
wasser in den fluss po von der
schneeschmelze doch schnee gab es wenig
im winter und in den bergen westlich von
turin gab es seit anfang des jahres zu
wenig niederschläge george otellini und
georgia kia no stellen extreme
trockenheit fest
es gibt keine bodenfeuchtigkeit selbst
bei 30 cm tiefe bleibt meine hand
treffen
sie fürchten einen gefährlichen sommer
der boden ist komplett ausgedacht
je länger die trockenheit anhält desto
einfacher entsteht ein brand
und bei einer solchen dürre kann auch
eine kleine flamme schnell zu einem
großen brand werden und waldbereiche
erreichen die sonst nicht betroffen
wären
am nächsten hand zeigt sich welche
dramatischen folgen dies hier in den
bergen haben kann im jahr 2017 hat dort
ein waldbrand gewütet damals von
menschen verursacht feuerbekämpfung war
fast nur aus der luft möglich bis heute
eine diesen wunde am berg die die
forstexperten mit neupflanzungen
schließen wollen die jetzt durch die
dürre gefährdet sind
diese kiefer hat große probleme man
sieht dass sie durst hat sie wird wohl
sterben weil sie nicht genug wasser
bekam der boden ist sehr trocken dieses
jahr und wenn das so weitergeht sind
auch alle anderen pflanzen die wir
gesetzt haben um den brandschaden zu
überwinden in gefahr könnten auch
eingehen
in der nähe haben sich wolken über den
gipfeln zusammengeballt ein zeichen dass
es regnen könnte endlich wenigstens
einen moment alles würde helfen
in der poebene wächst die verzweiflung
derweil werden die menschen im
ländlichen örtchen trezia video umwegen
der mailänder erzbischof mario del pini
es bekommen um sie zu unterstützen und
solidarität zu predigen
seit personen die die bescheidenheit als
tugend haben so dass auch bei dem
anderen genügend wasser ankommt für den
bedarf unserer böden und alle böden
die kirche ist voll gemeinsam beten sie
darum dass der himmel ist auf das
ausgedörrte land regnen lassen möge die
dürre beendet gegen die sie sonst nichts
tun kann
[Musik]